it was the spring of 1988 when I had the
aha moment I was at my first roundtable
and for those of you who don't know the
roundtable was a very commonly used
phrase on Wall Street to describe the
year-end evaluative process for analysts
associates vice presidents all the way
up to managing directors that was the
process where they were discussed behind
closed doors around the table ie the
roundtable and everyone was put into a
category the top bucket the middle
bucket the lower bucket and then that
was translated into a bonus range that
would be assigned to each professional
this was my first time there and as I
observed I saw that there was one person
that was responsible for recording the
outcome of a conversation there were
other people in the room that had the
responsibility of presenting the cases
of all the candidates and there were
other invited guests who were supposed
to comment as a candidates position was
presented it was interesting to me that
those other people were folks who were
more senior than the folks that were
being discussed and they theoretically
had had some interaction with those
candidates now I was really excited to
be at this roundtable for the first time
because I knew that my own process would
go through this same way and that my
bonus would be decided in the same way
so I wanted to know how it worked
but more importantly I wanted to
understand how this concept of a
meritocracy that every company that I
talked to walking out of business school
was selling every time I talk to a
company they would say our culture our
process is a meritocracy the way you get
ahead in this organization is that
you're smart you put your head down and
you work really hard and you'll go right
to the top so here was my opportunity to
see exactly how that worked so as the
process began I heard the recorder
called the first person's name
Joe Smith the person responsible for
presenting Joe's case did just that
three quarters of the way through
someone interrupted and said this is a
great candidate outstanding has great
analytical and quantitative skills this
is a superstar the recorder then said
sounds like Joe should go at the top in
the top bucket second person Mary Smith
halfway through that presentation
someone said solid candidate nothing
really special but a good pair of hands
the recorder said sounds like Mary
should go in the middle bucket and then
someone said Arnold Smith before the
person could present Arnold's case
somebody said disaster disaster this kid
doesn't have a clue can't do a model and
before the case was presented the
recorder said sounds like Arnold should
go in the bottom bucket it was at that
moment that I clutch my pearls
and say who's going to speak for me
who's going to speak for me it was at
that moment that I realized this idea of
a meritocracy that every organization
sells is really just a myth you cannot
have a hundred percent meritocratic
environment when there is a human
element involved in the evaluative
equation because by definition that
makes it subjective I knew at that
moment that somebody would have to be
behind closed doors arguing on my behalf
presenting content in such a way that
other decision-makers around that table
would answer in my best favor that was a
really interesting lesson and then I
said to myself well who is that person
what do you call this person and as I
thought about the popular business terms
at the time I said wow this person can't
be a mentor because of mentors job is to
give you tailored advice tailored
specifically to you and to your career
aspirations they're the ones who give
you the good the bad and the ugly in a
no-holds-barred way okay person can't be
a champion or an advocate because you
don't necessarily have to spend any
currency to be someone's champion you
don't necessarily get invited to the
room behind closed doors if you're an
advocate it was almost two years later
when I realized what this person should
be called I was speaking at the
University of Michigan to the MBA
candidates talking about the lessons
that I had learned after my three short
years on Wall Street and then it came to
me I said oh this person that is
carrying your interest or as I like to
say carrying your paper into the room
this person who is spending their
valuable political and social capital on
you this person who's going to pound the
table on your behalf this is a sponsor
this is a sponsor
I said to myself well how do you get a
sponsor and frankly why did you need one
well you need a sponsor frankly because
as you can see there's not one
evaluative process that I can think of
whether it's an academia health care
financial services not one that does not
have a human element so that means it
has that measure of subjectivity there
is a measure of subjectivity in who is
presenting your case there is a measure
of subjectivity in what they say and how
they interpret any objective data that
you might have there is a measure of
subjectivity in how they say what
they're going to say to influence the
outcome so therefore you need to make
sure that that person who is speaking
that sponsor has your best interests at
heart and has the power to get it
whatever it is for you to get it done
behind closed doors
now I'm asked all the time you know how
do you get one well frankly Nirvana
is when someone sees you in an
environment and decides I'm gonna make
it happen for you I'm going to make sure
that you are successful but for many of
us in this rule we know it doesn't
really happen that way so let me
introduce this concept of currency and
talk to you about how it impacts your
ability to get a sponsor there are two
types of currency in any environment
performance currency and relationship
currency and performance currency is the
currency that is generated by your
delivering that which was asked of you
and a little bit extra
every time you deliver upon an
assignment above people's expectations
you generate performance currency it
works is Jack exactly like the stock
market
any time a company says to the street
that they will deliver 25 cents a share
and that company delivers 40 cents a
share that stock goes up and so will
yours performance currency is valuable
for three reasons number one it will get
you noticed it will create a reputation
for you number two it will also get you
paid and promoted very early on in your
career and very early on in any
environment and number three it may
attract a sponsor why because strong
performance currency raises your level
of visibility in the environment as I
said earlier such that a sponsor may be
attracted to you why because everybody
loves a star but if you find yourself in
a situation where you don't have a
sponsor here's the good news
remember that you can exercise your
power and ask for one but here's where
the other currency is now most important
that is the relationship currency and
relationship currency is the currency
that is generated by the investments
that you make in the people in your
environment the investments that you
make in the people in your environment
you cannot ask someone to use their
hard-earned personal influential
currency on your behalf if you've never
had in the interaction with them it is
not going to happen so it is important
that you invest the time to connect to
engage and to get to know the people
that are in your environment and more
importantly to give them the opportunity
to know you because once they know you
is a higher probability that when you
approach them to ask them to be your
sponsor they will in fact answer in the
affirmative now if you're with me and
you agree that you have to have a
sponsor let's talk about how you
identify a sponsor well if you're
looking for a sponsor they need to have
three primary characteristics number one
they need to have a seat at the
decision-making table they need to have
exposure to your work in order to have
credibility behind closed doors and they
need to have some juice or let me say it
differently they better have some power
it's really important that they have
those three things and then
once you have identified the person how
do you ask for one the script goes like
this
Jim I'm really interested in getting
promoted this year I've had an amazing
year and I cannot show this organization
anything else to prove my worthiness or
my readiness for this promotion but I am
aware that somebody has to be behind
closed doors arguing on my behalf and
pounding the table you know me you know
my work and you are aware of the client
feedback and I hope that you will feel
comfortable arguing on my behalf if Jim
knows you and you have any kind of a
relationship there's a very high
probability that he will answer yes and
if he says yes he will endeavour to get
it done for you but there's also a shot
that Jim might say no and if he says no
in my opinion there's only three reasons
that he would tell you know the first is
he doesn't think that he has enough
exposure to your work to have real
credibility behind closed doors to be
impactful and effective on your behalf
the second reason he may tell you know
is that you think he has the juice to
get it done but he knows that he does
not have the power to do it and he is
not going to admit that in that
conversation with you and the third
reason that he would tell you know he
doesn't like you he doesn't like you and
that's that's something that could
happen but even that will be valuable
information for you that will help to
inform your next conversation with the
sponsor that might make it a little bit
more impactful I cannot tell you how
important it is to have a sponsor it is
the critical relationship in your career
a mentor frankly is a nice to have but
you can survive a long time in your
career without a mentor but you are not
going to ascend in any organization
without a sponsor it is so critical that
you should ask yourself regularly who's
carrying my paper into the room who's
carrying my paper into the room and if
you can't answer who is carrying your
paper into the room then I will tell you
to divert some of your hard-working
energies into investing in a sponsor
relationship because it would be
critical to your success and as I close
let me give a word to the would-be
sponsors that are in the room if you
have been invited into the room know
that you have a seat at that table and
if you have a seat at the table you have
a responsibility to speak
don't waste your power worrying about
what people are going to say and whether
or not they think you might be
supporting someone just because they
look like you if somebody is worthy of
your currency spend it one thing I have
learned after several decades on Wall
Street is the way to grow your power is
to give it away and your voice is at the
heart
[Music]
and your voice is at the heart of your
power use it thank you very much
[Applause]